c'est non non pour tuer le temps en
attendant la mort de nombreuses
personnes jouent à pincemi et pincemoi
avec l'être cher pas celui et pincemoi
sont dans un bateau passe me tombe à
l'eau qu'est ce qui reste
passe moi
[Rires]
malheureusement il arrive c'est quand on
a joué pendant plusieurs heures
d'affilée à pince mi pince moi une
certaine lassitude apparaissent chez
l'un des joueurs ou même si reed
c'est pourquoi j'ai inventé une variante
très amusante à ce jeu regardez bien ce
jeu s'appelle bombarde me bombarde mois
il se joue ainsi bombardier bombarde
mois sont dans un bateau bombard me
tombent dans l'eau qu'est ce qui reste
dambach mois
etonnant non
[Musique]